[Applaudissements]
c'est tellement horreur c'est tellement
ça nous avait raconté non je plaisante
j'ai fait du cinéma pour une fois je
peux vous la raconter vite fait parce
que je sais que vous êtes tous friands
l'anecdote j'ai tourné un film une fois
et je vous ai sur le tournage a duré
huit heures je jouais le rôle d'un
présentateur télévisé
je suis donc à mon journal pendant 8
heures ils m'ont fait faire du jt quand
le film est sorti au cinéma j'ai fait
venir toute ma famille est là je
découvre le montage je vois le méchant
rentrer dans la pièce je ne me vois pas
il allume la télé donc on me voit mieux
nos voix à 15 mètres dans un torrent ne
me reconnais pas et là on me voit faire
bonsoir et lui fais ta gueule et il
était
allez y compris un côté qui sont gênés
quand même qu'ils osent pas te regarde
c'est pas mal gens riches